>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mark Sweeney: Good
afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
I'm Mark Sweeney, the acting
Deputy Librarian of Congress.
And it's my pleasure
to welcome you
to the library's historic Thomas
Jefferson Building for which
to this afternoon's symposium,
the first public event
in the United States related to
the Georgian Papers Programme.
Launched in April of 2015,
the Georgian Papers Programme
is a collaborative effort led
by King's College London and
the Royal Collection Trust
to make an accessible and
extraordinary rich collection
of primary source material
from the Georgian monarchs,
including King George III,
the British monarch in power
when the American colonies
declared independence.
Comprising nearly 350,000
pages of correspondents, maps,
and royal household
ledgers, the Georgian Papers,
85% of which have been
unknown to scholars until now,
stand to revolutionize
our understanding
of 18th century British,
American, and Atlantic history,
an era of profound
cultural, political, economic,
and social change in many ways
continues to influence us today.
Last year, in one of the first
acts as Librarian of Congress,
Dr. Carla Hayden
signed an agreement
with King's College London
and the Royal Collection Trust
to collaborate on
digitization, dissemination,
and interpretation of the
papers of King George III
and the other Georgian
Papers' materials.
Over the next four years,
the Georgian Papers
Programme promises
to reveal many more dimensions
to Britain's longest reigning
king, allowing scholars
and the general public a
unique window into the life
and times of King George III.
The Library of Congress
holds the papers
of numerous United States
founders, including those
of George Washington, offering
historical context when paired
with the documents of
the Georgian Papers.
As such, it is quite
fitting for us
to actively embrace this
project, and my colleagues
and I are delighted to partner
with our peers both here
in the United States
and across the pond.
The Omohundro Institute
of Early American History
and Culture is the
primary US partner
for the Georgian
Papers Programme.
The Library of Congress
joins the Sons
of the American Revolution
and the Mount Vernon Ladies'
Association as a critical part
of the American Collaboration.
This afternoon's
symposium is hosted
by the John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress
in partnership with
the Omohundro Institute
and King's College London.
The Kluge Center brings together
scholars and researchers
from around the world
to stimulate
and energize one
another to distill wisdom
from the library's rich
resources and to interact
with policymakers and
the general public.
In a few moments, we will
hear from four scholars
who were recently
among the first
to examine the Georgian
Papers held at Windsor Castle.
Each scholar's presentation will
reveal their early findings,
describing for us some
of the remarkable historical
discoveries that are being made.
But before introducing them,
a few important announcements
related
to the library's participation
in Georgian Papers Programme.
First, a major exhibition, the
Two Georges is planned for 2020,
2021 to explore the overlapping
worlds of King George III
and George Washington, two
globally significant figures
of the late 18th century.
The exhibition, exploring the
commonalities and contrast
between the two men and
the global, political,
and cultural context of their
lives will open first here
at the Library of Congress
and subsequently at
a venue in London.
More details to come on
this exciting project
as it continues to develop.
And second, for those of
you who may be inspired
by today's event,
the library is proud
to announce a new
Georgian Papers fellowship.
Interested scholars may apply
for a two-month fellowship
to pursue independent
research in the Georgian Papers
of the Royal Archives at Windsor
and in the Early American
Collection at the Library
of Congress with one month
in residence in London
and one month in residence
here at the library.
The application deadline for the
Georgian Papers fellowship is
January 31, 2018, and the
fellowship recipient will be
selected based on the
relevance of their project
for research at both
institutions.
For more details, please
visit the Kluge Center website
at loc.gov/kluge.
Finally, the Library
of Congress would
like to thank our
generous donors, Beverly
and Lyman Hamilton, members
of the library's private-sector
support group, the John--
the James Madison Council, for
making this program possible.
We are delighted that Beverly
Hamilton is in the audience.
Mrs. Hamilton, would you
please stand and be recognized.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I will now turn the podium
over to my colleague,
Dr. Colleen Shogan, deputy
director for National
and International Outreach
here at the library.
Colleen is our Georgian Papers
Programme project manager,
and she's going to handle the
remainder of today's program.
Colleen. Thank you.
>> Dr. Colleen J.
Shogan: Thank you, Mark,
for those terrific
introductory remarks.
What a terrific moment
in history
for this Anglo-American
collaboration.
Of course, through the
Georgian Papers Programme,
the United Kingdom is
providing greater access
to important documents
and papers
that have gone largely
unexamined for many years.
And the United States,
as we all know, well,
we're great exporters.
Apparently these days, this
also includes princesses so--
That's a joke for old
folks, but we do want
to wish congratulations to
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle,
and we wish them the best.
There's a few people
I'd like to acknowledge
in the room before we begin.
First, the director of National
and International
Outreach, Jane McAuliffe.
Next, the director of the
Kluge Center, John Haskell.
And then I'd also like
to introduce you to two
of our exhibit-- lead
exhibit members of our team
for the Two Georges,
Julie Miller our historian
and our curator for the
Early American collections
and Cheryl Regan the
senior exhibit specialist
in charge of the Two Georges.
Lastly, I'd like to thank Travis
Hensley who worked very hard
to put this program
together, also in conjunction
with our special events team
here at the Library of Congress.
There will be plenty of time
at the end of the program
for questions, but we ask that
you hold all your questions
and your thoughts until
the end of the program,
after all the speakers
have spoken,
and then they will
join us on stage
to take all of your questions.
So now, I'd like to introduce
our first speaker, Arthur Burns.
We're very happy that Arthur
was able to make the trip today
from London to join us here
at the Library of Congress.
Arthur is a professor of
Modern British History
at King's College London,
historian of the Church
of England from the
18th to 20th centuries.
He was one of the editors of
the prize-winning "St. Paul's:
The Cathedral Church
of London" published
by Yale University Press in
2004, and is a director of one
of the first large-scale
public-facing online history
projects in the UK, The
Clergy of the Church
of England Database
1540 to 1835,
which he co-founded in 1999.
And most important
for our purposes,
he's the academic director of
the Georgian Papers Programme.
Arthur, the stage is yours.
>> Arthur Burns: Thank
you very much, Colleen.
And can I just say what a
pleasure it is to be here.
It's a really exciting
program for all of us involved.
But to come here and speak
at the Library of Congress,
as you can imagine, is
something of a treat.
So thank you, everybody,
who's made that possible.
So, my task this afternoon is
to introduce the Georgian Papers
and to say a little bit about
the project as a preface
to the reflections you will
hear from my colleagues
about their actual
researches into the program.
So they will be giving you the
hardcore research findings.
I'm going to try and give you a
sense about just how interesting
and exciting a program this is.
Now, I have to confess because
I'm a bit of an archives junkie.
I've spent the last 30 years on
and off investigating
the contents of archives
across the UK, some of which
are state-of-the-art archives
with the computer catalogs and
advanced access arrangements,
and others which conform
about the more popular
stereotype archives
with stone clad vaults
and cobweb documents.
The contents of which is
rather hard to predict
since we've actually blown the
dust physically off the boxes
and ledgers.
On the other hand, in
my capacity as director
of the clergy database
you just heard about,
I've also had 20 years
experience working getting
archival documents
online in the form
where the wider public can
access them and scholars
across the world
make use of them.
So if you think of the
two unique selling points
of Georgian Papers as
archival and online,
you might think this just feel
like another day at
the office for me.
That's far from it.
The Georgian Papers
are different
and I find myself absolutely
caught up in the excitement
that all my colleagues
here feel for the project.
I just hope I can get some of
that excitement across this.
I've been told to be lively.
I'll do my best with my cold,
but we'll see how we get on.
So a good place to start.
Well, maybe the actual archive
in which the Georgian
Papers are held.
Now in all kinds of ways,
this Windsor Castle conforms
to the archive as
impenetrable treasure chest
of popular imagination
and something
of that I think is
captured in the documentary
that BBC made a year ago to
introduce the Georgian Papers,
"The Genius of the Mad King".
[ Music ]
>> [Background Music] Windsor
Castle is the treasure chest
of royal secrets.
Here in the round tower
are the personal papers
of all British monarchs
and their families
from George III right down
to Elizabeth the second.
They've always been
out of bounds,
except to a few select
historians.
>> Documents that really
you're wanting to keep forever,
you think about a
strong place to put them.
And in the case of Windsor
Castle, the very strongest place
to put them is inside
the round tower.
And the round tower
is built on the site
where William the Conqueror
founded the castle in 1070.
And that settles the round tower
oval to the mid 12th century,
so for very sensible and very
secure place to keep papers.
>> Nowhere safer?
>> What's happening
here at the top
of these 104 stone steps
is history of sorts too.
Nearly two centuries
after George III's death,
all his private papers,
hundreds of thousands
of them are being
released to the world.
Now some may ask, why
has it taken so long?
But here in this fortified royal
vault, it's groundbreaking.
>> Never before has a group
of academics been allowed inside
the inner sanctum to rifle
through these invaluable
documents.
So the first visit of scholars
from King's College London,
partners in this project, was
a kind of royal revolution.
>> If you could break
yourself into groups
of three or four [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
>> Arthur Burns: So that's--
So from now I'm reporting
on that fondling
that was just described there.
And I think that does capture
just how difficult an archive
this has been to access in the
past, which is why we estimate,
as you already heard, that
despite the obvious importance,
only some 15% of the papers
which it contains have
ever been published.
In terms merely of its size,
with some 350,000 pages
of documents to appear
by the time the program
on digitization concludes,
this is clearly one
of the most significant
caches of 18th
and early 19th century papers
that will be made
widely available
to new audience for decades.
And it's not only a matter of
making available digital images
of the documents online.
The documents fit formally.
You could only get
to it by going to sit
in this glamorous reading room.
It sometimes feels a bit
like the historical versions
of prince and sleeping
beauties of hacking your way
into the round tower together.
Or indeed, so we're going
to digitize them, yes.
But of course, it's not just
the question of digitization
because some of the documents
are damaged and they have
to be conserved first before
they could be made available.
We also don't have a proper
catalog of these documents.
So a key aspect of the project
is going to be making a catalog
so we actually can describe
these documents the way it
should be confined with
appropriate metadata.
And we're probably going to
transcribe a fair number of them
as well into machine
readable text,
which for the first time enables
scholars really to engage
with these documents
in a serious way.
So, so far I think that document
should capture something
important but it also obscures
one or two key features
of the archives to make
it all the more intriguing
to us scholars.
And obviously one thing
that is obvious for this,
we thought all about George III.
We said George-- that there's
a lot about George III in here
and George III is obviously
of particular interest
with transatlantic audience
because of his rather
painful role
in the creation of your nation.
And the sense also that
he has a very long reign.
I mean he does stay around--
the longest reigning
monarch we have.
But it's really important,
don't forget this archive
also contains papers relating
to other monarchs, in
fact four of the monarchs.
George I came to
the throne in 1714.
His successor George II,
who reigned until George
III succeeded him in 1760.
And a much more significant
number of documents relating
to George's success of his
son George IV both as king
and when he was Prince
of Wales and regent.
And finally, there's a smaller
bunch of documents that relate
to the reign of William IV
under his death in 1837,
Victoria took the throne.
So the archive that gets
this inside is right
across the Hanoverian
period which even
without the American Revolution
would surely count as one
of the most significant
periods of British history.
Moreover, the archive also
contains papers relating
to many other members
of the royal family,
such as the monarchs' consorts
and children who's often
owned rather turbulent lives--
and there were some really
quite extraordinary life stories
in the immediate
family of the king.
Of equal interest to those
are the monarchs themselves.
Secondly, I think the
emphasis in the documentary,
the vault-like security
of Windsor Castle needs
to be balanced by the fact that
these archives weren't there
for a long time and they didn't
arrive there in the present form
until the early 20th century.
The bulk of the collection
has been left by George IV
to the care of his executor,
who just happened to be the Duke
of Wellington with
the instruction
to be destroyed unread.
Well, luckily for us, the
instruction was largely ignored
and as was the collection
itself until it was rediscovered
in 1912 in the basements
of Wellington's Apsley
House then transferred
to its present home in 1914.
So some records have
ever been consigned
to the fire before it went
to Wellington are bits
of the royal records which
clearly were not [inaudible]
of Queen Charlotte's
papers and disappeared.
Some of George III's early
papers have disappeared.
And that's the most
distressing one.
The years when George is dealing
with the other [inaudible]
in which a lot of
key policies relating
to North America
were being discussed,
some of those papers we
think are just missing.
Others suffer from the
neglect in the interim.
We do have damaged
documents from damp and all
of those other things reflect
things have not properly been
kept from the years
in Apsley House.
And this means we don't
therefore have a complete set
of all these monarchs' papers.
But against that,
we can set the fact
that these collections had been
augmented by gifts and purchases
which extended coverage to many
key men and women of the court
or the employee of the monarchs.
And we were already finding
that some of the key discoveries
that some of you will hear
about later are being made
among these tapes of the papers
that were those closely
associated
with the king [inaudible]
the king himself.
And those have not been
investigated anyway near as much
as the papers of George III's
own handwriting on them.
And then there were odd
additional items and of
such things of now that
are usually lurking
under that catchall title,
miscellaneous in the catalog.
And one such curiosity which
I think illustrates the kind
of things you can find
there is a pair of letters
from Admiral Lord Horatio
Nelson to Emma Hamilton.
And you can see a
little bit of one here.
Now, it's not hard to
assess why these documents
which have no immediate
or thorough connection
with the royal family end
up in the royal archives
in the 20th century for
in them Nelson warns Emma
that he's heard that the
Prince of Wales wants her
for her mistress and he's
trying to persuade her to stay
out of any contact with him
in any place lest this
happens [inaudible]
of events today this document.
The next [inaudible] is when you
would [inaudible] the evidence
that we might then hear
because they also illustrate
incidentally the force
of Nelson's passion.
I don't know how good
your paleography is,
but if you look closely
at the screen,
you'll see that in this excerpt
he declares his own feelings be
so strong that, "I
might be trusted
with 50 virgins naked
in a dark room."
So, that's Lord Nelson.
He was writing this after he'd
had his hand amputated as well,
so we [inaudible] as he's
dictating this to someone,
which is hard to imagine, but
probably he taught himself
to write with his other hand.
So, it was a private
communication.
It's important to
emphasize, I think therefore
that the sheer variety of
papers, the Georgian Papers,
is a key part of the importance.
And as we might expect,
both Andrew
and Jim will show you shortly,
discoveries in the papers
already shed new light
on politics, both domestic and
international in the period,
including the [inaudible]
relations of Britain
and the North American colonies
and then the United States.
But it goes also interactions
with Europe during
the revolutionary
and Napoleonic Wars
and with other parts
of the British Empire and
beyond, the Macartney mission
to China for example
being one of those.
And these are the
kind of revelations
that we might all expect
from the monarchs' papers.
But there's a lot
more to it than that.
And this pie chart, which
is a work in progress,
it changes every time I see it.
It tries to analyze
what we've got
in these papers in
breaking it down.
And anyone who is good
at taxonomy will instantly see
these are not a coherent set
of categories because we
have some personal names
of the [inaudible] themes
and therefore all kinds
of overlaps are taking
place here
within those broad
sways that's labeled
with a particular
monarch's name.
But even allowing for
all its weaknesses,
this does give you a sense of
the sheer variety of papers
which are in the documents
even before you take account
of the variety hidden behind
those monarchs' names.
There's lot here, for example,
the historian of science
and medicine manifest-- we know
after that George III was
famously ill for a long time
and awful lots of records
relating to the treatment
and diagnosis of that illness
and that often painful reading,
stuff relating to his
interest in scientific inquiry,
relating to a magnificent
collection
of scientific instruments that
my university is not fortunate
to own but you can see
through our kindness
in the science museum
where they were on display,
a magnificent collection
of telescopes
and [inaudible] and so on.
But you'll also get the emphasis
with the other family members
and they suffer from
distress in large variety
of illnesses between--
across the range of them.
And you'll find also lots of
stuff in their emotional lives,
of all these princes
and princesses often very
complex relationships often
ending tragically.
And again, anyone with an
interest in the history
of interpersonal
relations or gender history
from the people find awful lot
of [inaudible] material here.
Then there were papers
relating to the workings
of the royal households,
the knots and bolts
of keeping the show on the road
in terms of food, provisioning,
equipping the buildings
with objects, and so on.
And that's another very rich
dimension of the collection
which we only just began to
think about historians of art,
the book, or maps,
we'll find documents
that are absolutely vital
to interpreting magnificent
collections
of those objects held by the
British Library and at Windsor
and anyone who's
had a chance to look
at the map collection
of George III.
It's an absolute
fantastic resource.
If you didn't travel, this
was how he knew the world.
He looked at the
maps and pictures.
And that's how he understood
the world around him.
And of course the [inaudible]
because they bought lots
and lots of stuff, lots
of really important
for art historians you could
do an awful lot of these lined
up against the libraries
collections or against those
in the British Library.
Commissioning buildings,
commissioning paintings,
commissioning music,
handle festivals, right,
a part of George III's life.
So, something for everybody
is the basic message
and exploring the
papers we'll find a lot
about English monarchy
but also about societies
in which the monarchs lived
and also the societies
in which they didn't
live, those overseas
in which [inaudible] to rule.
And most-- many of the
papers I think which relate
to the less person
[inaudible] the monarch
of those we know
the least about.
And as we move into those,
I think it's very hard
to predict what we
find but there is going
to be some major new
agendas I think set
for researchers very
rapidly as we explore those.
That said even where we've
had papers that's already been
published, the program
is shedding new light.
And we can see for example,
where editions mistook
or omitted or misinterpreted.
And it's very striking
for example
that the very first
volume of published letters
of George III came out in
the 1920s by the librarian,
since then he produced a very
thick volume of correspondents.
One of his colleagues was
so outraged by the quality
of this edition that he then
published the hardback edition
of corrections to that
volume, to volume one
that was 100 pages long.
And yet that's the collection
we still have to work with.
So, we're going to put
these digitized images,
we're going to be looking
at those documents and new.
But also of course when you look
at the document in manuscript
or in the very high
quality digital
and if you see something
quite different
from when you look
at the printed page.
If you look at George
III's abdication letters
when he's drafting this
potential abdication speech,
he thinks he might need to
give shortly after the loss
of the American colonies.
It's one thing to read
the finished version.
But you look at the original
and you see the agonized
crossings out.
You see the rethinking
that's going on,
something about the
psychological state of mind
that comes across
[inaudible] in that form
that simply could not be
reproduced even if you try
to annotate a printed edition to
indicate all those corrections.
And I think we look at them
fresh again, if we're looking
at them as a document
rather than as part
of a narrative history
where maybe this is
reproduced as a part of a story.
And we know that he thought
of that abdication and we know
that it's part of the story
of George is agonizing
after the end of
the American war.
But nobody has ever
reported to say, well,
where did you get the
idea of abdicating from?
Because after all, this is was a
king who is very, very conscious
of being a divinely authorized
and responsible person
for his people, and yet here
he is starting to walk away,
walk away at the
moment when he knows
that this is a [inaudible]
no respect whatsoever
as potential monarch.
So how does he think this is an
exercise of his responsibilities
to his maker if he's doing that?
So we can rethink the questions
we ask about these documents,
I think, as we see
them as documents.
Another way we see [inaudible]
part of bigger collection,
because the proximity of
all these different themes
in one collection reflects
the very real proximity
of a monarchy where you
have a small court operating
in a very intimate setting
with politicians and princesses
and coaches and servants all in
a very limited particular space
and of course all at
the heart of London,
the leading world city
of the late 18th century.
We could therefore have to
think quite harder what the
interconnections are
among with those papers.
And that takes me into the
final we're going to talk
about which is how we then
add value to these images
into the collection of
objects we're making public.
And there is a fantastic
program of research that's going
on in association
with this program.
Thanks to King's and
the Omohundro Institute
and the generosity of our
associates at Mount Vernon
and the Sons of the
American Revolution
which we're enormously grateful,
now joined by the Library
of Congress if you heard more
than 35 scholars have already
been actively researching the
Georgian Papers as Georgian
Papers fellows exploring the
range of themes which match the
diversity of the archive itself.
A particular relevance
this afternoon for example,
we should note that the
Omohundro alone has now funded
more than a dozen scholars
working on an American
or Atlantic world
topics in this program.
And that's fantastic feature.
And for me, it's been terrific
because I'm a really bad example
to kind of put a historian
who doesn't ever look
up to other places doing my work
and having to work alongside
so many people working
in American themes
such as illuminated so many
things I just wouldn't have got
to without this program.
And I think that's true of
a lot of British historians.
There's something special I
think as well about having
so many people who can feedback
into the cataloging process
because that's going to help us
improve the means back to others
because we're thinking
about what these documents
are all the time the scholars
as well.
And also the fact we were
working on one archive.
And that for me says a really
special about this program.
Quite often I go to campuses
and the biggest difference
between me and the other people
there is we don't use the same
stuff and so we can't
find an easy common ground
on which to debate things.
Here we have a load of scholars
doing extraordinary different
things who've all been
physically working
on the same papers.
And we had a marvelous meeting
this September organized
by Omohundro where we brought
together 14 or 15 of the people
who already done work
to get papers and a lot
of the others came as well.
And the connections the people
were making of animal history
through to the highest
politics you can imagine
through the history of food
and the dining traditions
of the monarchy, the points
of sparking going off
suggesting people that you think
about new dimensions
[inaudible] research
on that context was
really wonderful.
And I really do think that's
going to be a big feature
to the program as we go forward
is that we accumulate more
and more of these fellows.
And indeed, we're now-- as we've
gone digital, as we have more
and more documents online,
that community doesn't have
to be just [inaudible], we
can have a digital community.
Two weeks ago, we
launched, The King's Friend,
which is online network
research to see opportunities
to advance the work
through the papers program.
And already more than 220
scholars joined that network.
About a third of those
were in the United States
but they're worldwide and they
come from department of history,
of literature, of art, of
music, and lots of curators
and archivists as well.
And then we're going to
be keeping them involved
with the project
as it goes forward,
having to give them advance
opportunities to look
at materials before
it goes public
so they can contribute the
interpretations for us.
It's a new approach to try to
bind people to approach you
like this, one which we
are really excited about,
which we hope will
feed into things
like the exhibitions we've been
hearing about as we go forward.
And of course the digital lets
you do is potentially make
relations with other archives
and put documents together
which you wouldn't always
be able to do physically.
And we hope to try and do some
of that with making connections
to other archives
online, particularly those
that are endangered, say those
in Jamaica or other places
where we might be able to make
connections with them and try
and do something together.
Another [inaudible] see
transcription going forward
with students, scholars,
and wide [inaudible] public
taking part in the act
to practice transcription and in
the interpretation of documents.
And already both
William and Mary
and King's both postgraduate
and undergraduate students have
the opportunity to get involved
in this project at first hand.
My own students at
King's selected each
of the document at random.
They would give them a free
choice to go to the archive
and find some things
that's both to them
and then they were
given 10 weeks
to produce an online digital
edition of that document.
And they came from all
kinds of disciplines.
So one of favorites
was a math student
who never had done any
history before and they went
into George's exercise books
as a young man and say,
what math is he doing?
Where is he getting
that math from?
And they identified
the textbooks he used.
Why he was doing this math,
is all about ballistics
so he could picture, you know,
the cannonballs landed
in the right place.
But no, it's a fantastic thing
for her to do to take ownership
of this, her own project
and we'll feed that back
into the archive project
because we didn't know this.
That student founded that
and that would be her
contribution to the project.
So that's a great thing I think,
putting research into the heart
of student's education.
We're next taking it schools.
I'm talking to the British
Historical Association building
a collection of documents will
be used in school when teaching
for [inaudible] school children
due the [inaudible] using
Georgian Papers to
illuminate the curriculum.
Not just about George III
but about literacy and things
as part of the school
curriculum.
So, all of those things
speak to what I found is
that digital was doing
the last 20 years.
It's an extraordinary
moment for us
that we can take our
serious scholarly work
without compromising
it in terms of rigor
or scholarship find
point connection
with the wider historical
public and work together to try
and improve and enhance
our interpretation.
It's a wonderful
thing to be able to do
and the Georgian Papers
project offers a possibility
of doing this with a
new set of documents
on a different scale
and internationally.
And that's just fantastic
I think for me.
That said, the work
professional scholars will be
at the core what
we're going to do
as you would like
to hear, folks.
And period we're dealing
with obviously is a complex
and extraordinary one
exhibiting both parallels
with their own time
and you can think
of the globalization
shifting political tectonics
that leave people wrong-footed
at every moment to what
to do next or how to act,
the impact in new media
like a very striking parallel
between the politics there
and now and rapidly evolving
social economic challenges.
There's also striking contrast,
we see the origins of many
of our contemporary
institutions and practices
and with very different
circumstances
in which they now operate.
And to make sense, that's
going to require a lot of skill
and patience and research as
well as a lot of foreknowledge
so we will need professional
historians.
So it's pleasure to be able to
hand over to three such scholars
who all got patience
and foreknowledge
and they will continue our
discussion by explaining some
of the themes that's researched
in the papers is
already highlighting.
Thank you very much.
Applause
>> Dr. Colleen J.
Shogan: Thank you, Arthur.
That was terrific.
Now I'd like to introduce
our second speaker.
Jim Ambuske is the former
post-doctoral fellow
in Digital Humanities at
the University of Virginia,
School of Law Library.
A historian of the
American Revolution
and the Early Republic,
Jim recently completed
his PhD at UVA.
In addition to his work
on the Georgian era,
he co-directs the Scottish Court
of Session Digital
Archive project
in the 1828 catalog project
at the UVA Law Library.
The later being an initiative
to reconstruct the law--
the legal library that
Thomas Jefferson created
for the University of Virginia.
Please join me in welcoming
Jim to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Jim Ambuske: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I just want to begin by thanking
Karin and Shaun and Colleen
and Travis for inviting
me here today.
It's nice to see some
of my fellow fellows
from the Georgian
Papers project.
Two years ago I had
the good fortune
of being the first
Omohundro fellow to be
in the Georgian archive.
I beat my fellow over
there by about a month.
So now I'm giving a talk
in the Library of Congress.
I'm not sure it's going
to get any better so I'd
like to announce my
retirement at the conclusion
of today's program [laughter].
I wanted-- I'd like to tell
you about my time in Windsor
and a bit about my
research there
by telling you a
story about two men.
Admiral Sir Samuel Hood
and General Jacob De Bude.
These are common household
names in the history
of the American Revolution
although it's entirely possible
and you probably have
heard of Lord Hood.
But they shared a correspondence
during a critical period
of the American warfare
independence.
Letters that I found locked away
in the royal archives
of Windsor Castle.
By necessity, then this story
begins not of the 18th century
but on the 21st on a
cool September morning,
two years ago in
the round tower.
I applied for my Georgian
Papers fellowship hoping
to find material for
my dissertation project
which was a study of Scottish
immigration to North America
in the era of the
American Revolution.
And I found that other
evidence in some archives
that George III was aware what
some amongst the Scottish elite
described as a depopulation
crisis in Scotland.
In other words they believed
that a combination of factors
that push Scots out of
Scotland and pull them
to the colonies here would
deprive Britain of laborers
and soldiers at a critical
moment in the imperial crisis.
And so as I waited
through boxes of material
on the royal archives,
seeking answer to my questions,
I ask to see the papers
of General Jacob de Bude,
the man so honored here
by this inscription
within Saint George's
chapel located just
down the hill from
the round tower.
Born in Geneva in the early
18th century, as a younger man,
de Bude acted as a military page
for George III's great uncle
William, Prince of Orange.
He later served in
a Swiss regimen.
In 1772, de Bude joined
the British royal household
to oversee the education
of the princes William
Henry and Edward.
George III made him a
general in the Hanoverian army
and apparently became
the king's aide-de-camp.
He later served as Prince
Frederick's secretary
and it was Frederick who
placed memorial to de Bude
in St. George's Chapel,
a testimony to that man's long
service to the royal family.
And so on that September
morning, in 2015,
I received a red archival box
similar to what Arthur showed
in the video there containing de
Bude's papers hoping upon hope
that they pour something
directly
on my dissertation topic
hoping that I find a letter
from the king where he's
talking to de Bude in confidence
about this potential crisis.
And I didn't find
anything, but that's OK.
And part of the process of
this program is to figure
out what is there and
what is not there.
And as I'd like to say,
what I found is better
in more instances that one,
and so in that box sandwiched
between account books and
a collection of recipes.
So if you need anything for
the holidays, let me know.
I found a catch of letters
wrapped in brown paper
and bound together
by a piece of string.
Opening that package
I discovered
about 140 letters plus
enclosures written
to de Bude from Admiral Hood.
Here was a collection unknown
to scholars, dating between 1781
and 1783, written by one of
Britain's senior naval officers
to one of George III's
trusted men in the last years
of the revolutionary war.
I wonder what it could mean
that these letters existed
in this collection within
this particular archive
and what they might tell
us about the relationship
between these two men, about
the American Revolution
and about George III.
To begin to answer
those questions,
we need to know something
about de Bude's correspondent,
Admiral Hood.
A season naval veteran,
Hood first went to see
with the royal navy
in the 1740s.
Served in a seven years war,
what we commonly called
the French-Indian war
in North America,
stationed in Halifax,
Nova Scotia in the years
before the American Revolution,
served as a commissioner
of the naval yards
at Portsmouth, England.
Before becoming a flag
officer in the British fleet
in the early 1780s, confident
in his own abilities,
often to the point of arrogance,
Hood all too easily found fault
in the conduct of his fellow
officers, even his superiors.
He was not afraid to express
his opinions to his friends
and to his civilian superiors
and the luminous correspondents.
But it was never without a
point and that's important,
Hood wanted his correspondents
to understand
where the officers had gone
wrong, wanted to expose flaws
in British military strategy
and wanted to offer a sense
of the potential consequences
of certain military choices.
Now of course, you know,
Hood, he's not writing this
without an eye towards his own
conduct, his own reputation.
He wants his correspondents
to hold him in high regard.
But he generally believed
in the righteousness
of the British cause
in suppressing the
American rebellion.
He was content on doing his duty
to king, country, and empire.
And he was also a
politically astute man.
He was well versed
in 18th century ideas
of duty, honor, and propriety.
While he was on friendly
terms with the king,
Hood dared not flout
the chain of command
and send his grievances
directly to George III.
And so with that in mind, I
want to emphasize the importance
of to whom Hood is writing.
True, some of what Hood wrote
to de Bude mirrored what
he communicated to others.
But the fact that he provided
de Bude one of the king's men
with detailed accounts
of the war effort
and the people involved
raises [inaudible] prospect
that Hood saw these letters
as way to back-channel
to George III himself.
Hood's correspondence with
de Bude written in the wake
of a catastrophic British defeat
in the late summer of 1781,
offers an excellent
example of the kind
of information he might have
conveyed to this exchange.
They help illuminate a fatal
moment and the people involved
in Britain's efforts to
subdue the rebellion.
And so most of us are aware
I think with the Battle
of Yorktown of October 1781,
the victory by the combined
Franco-American army
that traps Cornwallis southern
Army on New York peninsula
and leads to peace
negotiation with the Americans.
Certainly if you're familiar
with the Hamilton's soundtrack,
you know this by heart
by now [laughter].
Far fewer know much about
the Battle of the Chesapeake,
just one month before on
September the 5th, 1781.
This was the decisive
naval engagement
of the American Revolution,
especially with respect
securing American independence.
It is difficult to imagine
Cornwallis' surrender
without it.
The clash of the Virginia coast
was a reflection of Britain's--
the British military
and southern strategy
in this period of a war.
After John Burgoyne's
surrender at Saratoga in 1777
and France's formal entry into
the war the following year,
the British military
concentrated its efforts
in the southern colonies,
partly in the belief and not
without good reason that they
would find greater numbers
of loyal Americans in the south.
In for a time, the
British found success.
They actually re-conquered
Georgia in the fall of 1779.
That colony is declared at
the king's peace, all right?
So that's one check mark.
In May 1780, they captured
Charles Town, South Carolina,
all right, captured one
of the southern coast's
most important ports.
And after Charles Town
falls into British hands,
Lord Cornwallis takes
command of the southern army,
spends the better part of the
next year and a half working
to pacify South Carolina where
a very violent civil war breaks
out between patriot and
loyalist, moving north
into North Carolina and
finally into Virginia.
And in Virginia, he has orders
from General Sir Henry Clinton
to establish a fortified
position near a port
to which the British
could send supplies.
And all the while,
American continental
and militia forces are
harassing him and his men.
By the summer of 1781,
George Washington
and de Rochambeau
sense an opportunity.
Stationed up the Hudson River
near White Plains, New York,
the two generals debated
whether to launch a strike
against the British
headquarters in New York City,
a city that the British
[inaudible] of the war
or to begin an offensive
in Virginia to capture
or destroy Cornwallis'
southern army.
And ultimately they
choose Virginia largely
because Rochambeau convinces
Washington who really wants
to just go in there and get
the crap out of the British
in New York that Virginia
is the better option.
But with the British Navy
patrolling American waters,
Washington and Rochambeau
needed the assistance
of the French fleet to
accomplish their objectives.
One small French naval force lay
off Rhode Island while another
under the command of Admiral
de Grasse was soon expected
on the West Indies.
If you'd like to know more
about the American Revolution
in the Caribbean,
I encourage you
to read Andrew O'Shaughnessy's
book "An Empire Divided".
It's terrific.
Go pick up your copy today.
And once that fleet arrives,
Rochambeau sends a message
to de Grasse asking him
to bring his fleet north
to assist the allied armies
marching toward Virginia.
The British had a fleet in
the West Indies as well,
one that included Hood
abort his flagship.
And the British rightly
suspected
that their enemies were
preparing a joint operation
either against General
Clinton's forces in New York
or against Lord Cornwallis
in Virginia.
The senior British
admiral ordered Hood
to take a detachment of 14 ships
of the lines to the battleships
to track de Grasse after the
French commander began the
voyage north.
Because Hood took a more direct
route to the American mainland,
he actually passes
de Grasse and arrives
in Chesapeake Bay
on August 25, 1781.
Finding no French ships in
the bay, Hood sailed north
to New York City to
consult with Admiral Graves
who had the overall command
with the British fleet
in North America at this time.
And when Hood, Graves, and other
officers observed the sailing
of the French fleet at Rhode
Island, they correctly suspected
that Virginia was the target.
Mobilizing a combined fleet
of 19 ships of the line,
the British sailed south
to prevent the French
from isolating Cornwallis' army.
And here you have a map from
the Library of Congress,
depicting this battle.
And the British fleet is--
are the darker of
the two colors there.
On September the 5th, 1781,
Hood, Graves, and the rest
of the British fleet encountered
de Grasse and his force
of 24 ships of the line near
the mouth of Chesapeake Bay.
Outnumbered, outgunned,
outmanned,
the British nevertheless
put up a decent fight
for a few hours before
being forced to withdraw.
De Grasse's victory
left the French
in command of Virginia waters.
Tracking Cornwallis on land
has the Franco-American army
drew near.
Despite the magnitude
of this defeat,
Admiral Hood was
not lost for words.
He sent letters
to correspondents
including Jacob de Bude,
describing the battle in what he
thought it meant for the faith
of Britain's American empire.
He composed a long letter to de
Bude 11 days after the battle,
in which he noted, "On
the 5th instant, at 11 am,
we plainly discovered 24 sail
of French ships of the line
and two frigates at
anchor about Lynnhaven Bay,
which afforded the British
fleet a most glorious opening
for making a close
attack to advantage
but it was not embraced.
But with this letter,
Hood also included a copy
of his thoughts composed on
the morning after the battle.
Although uncharacteristically
short nevertheless,
Hood was characteristically
blunt
in his assessment of the battle.
And this is the message
he wants to convey
to his correspondents
including de Bude.
"Yesterday the British
fleet had a rich
and most delightful harvest
of glory, presented to it,
but admitted to gather it
in more instances than one."
And here we see a fine example
of Hood noting the failure
of a superior officer's judgment
in superiority of his own.
Hood argued that Admiral
Graves who commanded the center
of the British line
failed to press the attack.
He believed that if Graves
had exploited weak points
in the French line, it
might have been able Hood
to cut the French
center to pieces.
But as Hood sought, Graves
failed to act decisively.
In this another letters,
Hood made claim to de Bude
that defeat on the
5th of September along
with the later decision not to
mount another rescue effort,
portended doom for Lord
Cornwallis, his army,
and the British war effort.
I found in this particular
collection, he writes letters
on the 24th of September where
he describes the council of war
and Hood is desperately arguing
that the British should send
fire ships in to French lines.
Basically they would set their
own vessels on fire and ram them
into the French fleet as
a means to punch a hole
to rescue Cornwallis, and he
can't convince them to do it
and he is just beside himself.
He's really quite passionate
about what he thinks is
the right thing to do.
In the intimate nature
of this correspondence
between these two important
figures in the British military
and in the royal household
and the implication
that it may represent a
means to convey information
to George III, compels
us to ask new questions
about various aspects of
the American Revolution.
You know, in this town we
like to ask what did
the president know
and when did he know it.
And we can modify that
question to ask with, well,
what did the king know
and when did he know it?
And so I want to leave you with
the idea that the significance
of the Hood-de Bude letters
is that they are suggestive
of a broader and formal
intelligence network
that George III used to gather
information about the progress
of the American war,
developments
in Europe, and matters at home.
George III took his duties
as sovereign seriously
as Arthur suggested, making
it a point to know as much,
if not more about policy,
politics, and military strategy
as the ministers who ran his
government and his empire.
And for a king who gave his
last full measure of devotion
to the preservation of that
empire and whose ministers had
to drag him to the conclusion
that Britain could not win
this imperial civil war,
letters such as these along
with other evidence can give
us a new window not only
into naval history,
military history,
but also into the king's mind.
The letters between the admiral
and the aide-de-camp tell us
much about the relationship
between Hood and de
Bude and Hood's service
on the oceanic front lines
of the American rebellion,
yet they raised exciting
new questions
about George III's
American Revolution.
And now through the Georgian
Papers project and generosity
of many, many people here and
not, we are getting access
to the-- that archive
that will help us
to answer those questions.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Colleen J.
Shogan: Thank you, Jim.
Our next speaker is Andrew
Jackson O'Shaughnessy,
who is the vice president
of Monticello,
the Saunders Director
of the Robert H. Smith
International Center
for Jefferson Studies
and Professor of History
at the University of Virginia.
He is a dual citizen of
Britain and the United States.
His most recent book,
"The Men Who Lost America:
British Leadership, the American
Revolution, and the Fate
of the Empire" received eight
national books awards including
the New York Historical Society
American History Book Prize,
the George Washington Book
Prize, and the Society
for Military History Book Prize.
A fellow of the World Historical
Society, he is an editor of--
for the Journal of
American History.
Andrew, we welcome you
to the Jefferson Building
of the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Andrew O'Shaughnessy:
I'd like to begin
by thanking the Library of
Congress especially Colleen
and her colleague Travis Hensley
who've been primarily involved
in coordinating this.
I also want to thank the Sons
of the American Revolution.
And I put a slide there of my
giving lecture sponsored by them
for two months at King's
College London University.
They paid for me
essentially for two months
to be a visiting professor
at King's in association
with King's College Joe Dooley,
a former director general
who's sitting in the third row.
And he's really led
that organization
in a remarkable direction to
do many more academic programs
to have regular academic
conferences and make it more
than simply a social
organization.
And also, I would like
to thank King's College
and especially Arthur Burns
who hosted me very warmly,
that the faculty do make
visitors really feel part
of the college while they're
there even though one's spending
most of your time at Windsor.
Now my objective now is going
to be to show you the importance
of this archive for
American history
and specifically the
American Revolution.
And this is why I applaud
the Library of Congress
and the Kluge Center
for its involvement
and because this is important
albeit for the British side
of the American Revolution.
But the British side
is very essential part
of understanding the American
Revolution more generally.
George III was in some ways
the last king of England
to rule in any real sense.
It might be said by pedants
that there are important moments
where monarchs did
intervene like William IV
with the reformat-- and even
most recently the Queen in 1963,
she appointed a prime
minister, Sir Alec Douglas-Home
who was virtually unknown
at the time in a situation
of the gridlock in parliament.
But George III letters
has always been debated
as to whether it
was a constitutional
or unconstitutional monarch.
George III did have real power.
And he was able to choose
members of the cabinet
and he was able to choose
the prime minister as long
as he chose a prime minister
who generally had
support in parliament.
But that gave him
a lot of leeway.
George III was not responsible
for the policies that led
to the American Revolution
even though he's blamed as such
by the declaration
of independence.
And John Adams in retirement
complained to Thomas Jefferson
that he shouldn't have
called George III a tyrant.
But George III does become
the leading war hawk.
And this is one of the reasons
that these are the key papers,
the papers of George
III for high politics
and the military during
the American Revolution
from the British side.
Unfortunately, the papers
of Lord North are very
disappointing and very limited.
The only papers that really
compete would be those
of the colonial office
in the national archives.
George III essentially
became obsessed with this--
with the issue of America
after the Boston Tea Party.
That was the moment that he
decided that war was inevitable
and he became, in the words
even of his own admirers,
almost his own prime minister.
He dominated Lord North who was
constantly trying to resign,
who lost faith in the
conflict very early on.
He refused to negotiate
with opposition leaders
who were committed to withdraw
from America as early as 1778.
And he was almost
Churchillian in the words
of Herbert Butterfield
who was a historian
at Cambridge during
the Second World War
and wrote this shortly
afterwards that he reminded
of Churchill when
he read phrases like
"If any 10 men will stand
beside me, I intend to go on."
George III was so obsessed
that he actually threatened
his abdication during the war
before-- long before he wrote
the actual abdication letter.
And when he heard about the
news of Yorktown, he sent--
well, up today, we would
think of almost like an email
because George III,
whenever he was writing,
would put the exact
time of the day almost
to the last second on the note.
But in this particular message,
which was sent to the secretary
of state for America in his
house in Pall Mall in London,
he failed even to put
the date which shows
that there was a certain anxiety
because he just heard
about Yorktown.
And he wrote to Germain who
was dining with nine guests.
And the nine guests were unaware
in fact to the news of Yorktown
but they knew something major is
happening when the message came
from the king late at night
during a dinner party.
And one of the guests happened
to say that they'd heard
that the French foreign
minister died and how sad
because the minister would
never know what the outcome
of the American Revolution was.
And Germain-- Lord Germain
said he did know the outcome
of the American Revolution.
And most of the party
at that point felt
that they were referring to the
Battle of the Chesapeake Capes,
because most people
still expected Cornwallis
to be victorious.
They're even calling
him an English Hannibal
in the British newspapers.
And then Germain passed
around the message
which said he'd heard that
Cornwallis had surrendered
at Yorktown but we
intend to go on.
This is a minor setback
like Saratoga but most
of the army is still
in place in New York.
We still have cities throughout
the eastern seaboard including
Savannah or in Charleston.
We still got Canada
and we will fight on.
And indeed, one of the reasons
that North eventually
resigned was
because he couldn't really
persuade the king for him
to be able to give an
unequivocal commitment
that Britain would
withdraw from America.
And opposition leaders
came in to replace him.
George III during the American
Revolution made his main palace
outside of London Windsor
Castle, where the archives are.
And that is the round tower
where they're contained.
I've always started
symbolically quite significant
that he would base himself
in a castle during the war
because both-- his father died
of course before becoming king
but his grandfather George II
and his great grandfather
George I,
both of them [inaudible]
Windsor Castle.
In fact, a lot of work had to
be done to make it inhabitable.
George III would have military
music played constantly there.
He even designed the kind
of uniform coat wear
called the Windsor uniform
that was introduced
towards the end of the war.
And he obsessed about
every detail of the war.
And that is very apparent
when you start to go
through the correspondence.
Now, Arthur alluded
earlier to the fact
that correspondence was
published in the '20s
by a man called Sir
John Fortescue,
who's a remarkable librarian
of the royal archives
and a remarkable historian
who wrote multi-volume
histories of the British army.
And although in terms
of their interpretation
of attitudes, they're
very dated.
Nevertheless, John Shy,
one of the America's
leading military historians
of the American Revolution,
he recently reprinted
the section dealing
with the American Revolution
because he particularly admired
the way Fortescue is very easily
and briefly able to
summarize battles and events.
But the problem with that
correspondence is firstly it's
incomplete as we
again see in a moment.
Secondly, his author alluded
it's not really reliable.
And it was Sir Lewis
Namier who's regarded as one
of Britain's leading
20th century historians,
who went through just the first
year and produce the volume
of corrections and amendments
to Fortescue's series.
Incidentally, that
had a credible effect
to all documentary
editors afterwards.
It sent shivers people
spying that because a lot
of these changes were
hardly significant,
nevertheless it was a warning
never to entirely rely on this--
on the printed edition.
Thirdly, actually seeing the
original documents is in itself,
does influence your
reading of them.
This on the screen is a list
of George III's own hand
of ships of the French Navy.
And one of the most
remarkable things to me--
and I was actually curious
about George III's influence
on strategy because like the
president of United States,
he was commander-in-chief
of the army.
But he actually knew by
name most of his officers.
He was also the most proficient
monarch in naval affairs
since at least William
III, if not the equal
of someone like James II.
Supposedly, he knew off by
heart the soundings and depths
of various harbors
around Europe.
And I found lots of
letters and lists
where he'd copied
in his own hand.
The most remarkable is in fact
the Siege of Boston in 1775
where he's got information
about ordnance.
And what he do is he'd receive
the official papers from one
of the secretaries of
state usually germane
and then he copy it out.
So, what was the
discovery for me was
that of course he
had no secretary.
This material was
thought of as so private.
And he remained without
a secretary
until really quite later on
when ill-health forced him
to have a secretary.
And so, all of this
material is in his own hand.
Thanks to his keeping letters
and papers that we have so much
of Lord North's correspondence
because North didn't keep
as much for his own part.
I mentioned that a lot of
papers that are admitted
by Sir John Fortescue, the most
entertaining are the series
of the letters from a spy, and
it might have actually been more
than one person, who
signs himself Aristarchus.
I was asked by the BBC, was he
a kind of James Bond figure?
And I said, I didn't think so
because he describes himself
as being in his late 60s.
Although he said he felt like a
younger man, sort of 40 years,
his junior, but he was very
much stationary in London
but receiving intelligence
reports especially from France.
One of them describes a plot
that they thought was
an assassination plot.
They said the French know that
you often are seen walking alone
in your garden without
anyone around you,
and so that this was a warning.
Another more entertaining
one was
that a British agent had
been put up a chimney
in which Benjamin Franklin--
a room in which Benjamin
Franklin was meeting
with the emperor of Austria
to overhear the conversation.
But some of it goes beyond.
And I always imagine
that Fortescue
as a military historian
is mystic
because he didn't think the
intelligence is very good.
That was always been my guess.
So, I really don't understand
why would particular letters--
there are even letters of Lord
North that are not printed
in the correspondence.
I'm not sure if it
was just negligence
or if he had a specific reason.
But there are other
intelligence reports
that really are very important.
I thought one of the most
important came in a booklet
and it's from 1777,
1781 and it's a book
of naval intelligence by British
spies based near the coast near
the port of Brest watching the
movements of the French fleet.
And that is pretty critical
because one of the reasons
that British got it wrong
in Yorktown is that one
of the only times in the war
they had bad naval intelligence.
The British planned to have a--
what was known as
a [inaudible] navy.
And that would be navy that was
strong enough to defeat France
and Spain simultaneously.
Nearly for all of
the 18th century,
the British had naval
superiority.
It was the basis
of their empire,
their control of the seas.
But the battle of the
Chesapeake Capes is one
of the only battles
they really lost.
And it was a loss
even though much
of it was simply drifting apart.
But the fact that the
British were not able
to defeat the French
Navy and open
up the Chesapeake
represented a major defeat.
And one of the reasons
was bad intelligence.
And he's very curious
because the two commanders,
army commanders would blame
each other after the war.
Sir Henry Clinton, the
commander-in-chief in New York,
Lord Cornwallis in Yorktown,
they would blame each other and
yet both have been misled
and both had preceded
on the assumption that Britain
would've had the superior navy.
Had they done so, it
would've been possible
to simply ferry Cornwallis out
Yorktown and to get him back
to New York or to Charleston.
Other papers that are
important and they're more
than just papers of George III,
Jim spoke about Sir
Samuel Hood's papers
and those papers are
very interesting too
for the royal family
because Sir Samuel Hood
for a long while looked
after Prince William.
It was part of George III's
obsession with this war
that he sent two of his
own sons into the military,
one into the army and the
14-year-old Prince William
into the navy where he
essentially was eye witness
to some horrendous
moments almost
from the moment that
he left England.
The father was incredibly
disappointed with him later
on because he acquired
such foul language, manners
and alcohol habits from
his time in the navy.
But Hood oversaw him and
gives us a lot of information.
Hood was also in the Caribbean.
So, it's a very important source
for naval warfare
in the Caribbean.
These materials were
never used by any
of Sir Samuel Hood's
biographies.
So they really were unknown
and they do represent a
very major new discovery.
A third set of papers that
are important are those
of Prince William
himself who corresponded
with his father throughout.
He was the only member of
the British royal family
to visit America before
it became independent.
And what was most dramatic
to me was his descriptions
of British occupied New York.
And what was amusing was
his description of arriving
and he was greeted by Henry
Clinton who's commander-in-chief
who you think might had other
preoccupations at the time
because this was literally
about a month before Yorktown
where people are going mad
in New York with the fleet
of Sir Samuel Hood
having returned,
knocked about by de Grasse.
And supposedly they were trying
to refit it and repair it to go
and have another attempt
to release Cornwallis.
But when Prince William arrived,
he met Sir Henry Clinton
and he walked through what
he called the Parade Ground
but what we call Bowling Green.
And at this moment,
his relationship
with his father was
incredibly tense
because the father really
was upset by now at the sort
of relationships the
son was developing,
the fact that he
wasn't studying.
And he said as he walked
through Bowling Green,
and I saw the pedestal
where once he imagined the
statue stood [laughter].
And it's difficult not to think
that this was a [inaudible]
dad [laughter].
Also, part of the papers,
although they are being
digitally copied separately,
but an important part of
the papers are the maps
and military plans
and engravings
in the royal collection.
These are very remarkable.
I looked at several,
the Bunker Hill,
and I initially thought
I recognize these.
These are the famous plans of
Bunker Hill that you'll see them
in almost every textbook.
And then I realized they showed
different parts of the day
of Bunker Hill that these
had not been reproduced.
Now, I can tell you
that the Library
of Congress actually
did microfilm
of these many years ago,
but I don't think many people
would be aware of that.
But the Library of Congress is
the most important secondary
repository for a lot
of British materials.
They copied all of the
colonial office materials many
decades ago.
So it's an excellent
place to come
and study the American
Revolution.
Nevertheless, when
you're dealing with maps
and engravings, you
really do want
to see the original not
look at it on microfilm.
And finally people
mentioned that there are lots
of miscellaneous papers at least
to do with trying to get his--
buy out his son from letters
that the son had
foolishly written--
this was the future George IV--
to his mistress and the father
had to pay a lot of money
to get these letters back.
The woman involved was a very
smart actress and she managed
to secure a very
large sum of money.
She then went on to be the
partner [inaudible] probably the
most hated British
officer in America
but it's often said although
people regard [inaudible]
memoirs as a lot of
lies, but they're some
of the best written memoirs
by any British soldier.
But that's because she was
a novelist and a writer
and it almost certainly a
ghost written his memoir.
All I can say by ending and any
of you might consider applying
for this fellowship, is
that it's just the most
wonderful location.
These are a few photos that
I just took with my iPhone.
The Nell Gwynn coffee house
supposedly there are tunnels
from that coffee house
which Nell Gwynn used
to see Charles II.
There's a changing
of the guard just
like Buckingham Palace everyday.
And of course it's terribly
tempting because I meant
to be inside the castle.
But there's always so much
going on outside and, you know,
just observing sunset-- there's
an even song there everyday,
a beautiful song, even
sung in St. George's Chapel
where Elizabeth I
is also buried.
And it's worth going to just
purely as a good concert
and you can also
get free admission
to the castle if you go to that.
So I'll just leave you
with those visitors.
But I'll end by saying I think
that is wonderful the Library
of Congress is involved.
I've met with Carla Hayden
at Monticello and again
at the British embassy.
I know how personally
enthusiastic she is
about this program.
But what I really liked
and especially when I came
for planning session of the
exhibits on the Two Georges
that they're planning is
that this clearly is not
a top-down enthusiasm,
there's real enthusiasm among
the staff of this relationship.
And in the museum
and library world,
these kinds of collaborations
are becoming more
and more important.
So, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Colleen J. Shogan: Last
but certainly not the least.
It's my distinct honor
to introduce Karin Wulf.
Karin is a historian
of early America
and the early modern Atlantic
world focused on gender,
family, and the state.
She is director of the
Omohundro Institute
of Early American History
and Culture and a professor
of History at the College
of William and Mary
where she directs
graduate student research
in early American
and gender history.
She is a founder and
co-chair of the William
and Mary's Neurodiversity
Initiative and a co-founder
of Women Also Know History,
a media and curriculum tool
for supporting and advancing
the work of women historians.
And most importantly,
she is the academic lead
for the Georgian Papers
Programme in the United States
and is proven to be a terrific
colleague and collaborator
for the Library of Congress
and our GPP partnership.
Karin, we look forward
to your presentation.
[ Applause ]
>> Karin Wulf: Well first, I
want to thank our colleagues
and host here, of course first
of all Colleen but also John
and Travis and others for
joining us in the work
of the Georgian Papers
Programme and in helping us
to bring attention to its
work and its potential.
I also want to thank some absent
friends, colleagues especially
at the royal archives whom
you saw in some of the images
that Arthur shared and who
are scanning, cataloging,
and posting the materials on the
Royal Collection Trust website
and aiding of course all
of the scholars now working
in the materials both the
physical archive at Windsor
and the digital archive that
we're producing collaboratively.
So the documentary from which
Arthur shared some clips,
Robert Hardman's
"Genius of the Mad King",
was on BBC last January
as a way of introducing
to the British public, the
Georgian Papers Programme.
And actually all four of us
appeared in the documentary.
Jim used to actually saw
Arthur among that collaboration
of scholars there in the
first clutch, you know,
getting to touch the
materials and so on.
And he and Jim and Andrew
are each interviewed
in the documentary
about their research
and about the wonderful
findings.
From my rather ignominious part
in the documentary, I was filmed
at an event almost two and a
half years ago now, on April 1st
of 2015 about two dozen of us
gathered in the royal library
at Windsor where Her Majesty the
Queen formally inaugurated the
project and we were
all introduced.
And it was quite
wonderful of course.
She's kind of extraordinary.
And I was babbling
a bit with her
about the excitement
of the archives.
So, that's the piece
that made it
into the documentary [laughter].
Now I've been reliably
informed that many people start
to babble a bit when
in the presence.
But honestly, my enthusiastic
fulminating wasn't entirely
about speaking with the queen.
Anyone who's enthusiastic,
whatever you're enthused about,
whether you're into cars
or knitting or fine wine
or barbecue or founding father
saltshakers is actually a thing
will know that a fantastic
example of the object
of your enthusiasm will
make you completely gaiety.
So yes, the archives themselves
are absolutely fabulous.
King George III wasn't
employing a secretary
at an arguably enormously
important period
in the history of
our two countries.
So to handle those
materials, to see the shade
and feel the weight
of the paper,
to look at where he lifted the
quill or maybe press too hard
to make a point, a point
that were directly on the war
that created our country, well,
the physical object itself
is beyond compelling.
But even that isn't what made
me quite so kind of nutty
in that film clip that
I'm purposely not sharing
with you [laughter].
What compels us still
as we explore
and shape this project going
forward is really the potential
of the project.
Refresh historical understanding
that is really what makes
this project so exciting.
I don't think there's anyone
here that I have to persuade
about the importance of history.
I'm going to just go
with assuming that.
But history is the context
in which we make decision,
everyday consequential and
minute, domestic and national.
And these archives give
us an opportunity to think
with fresh evidence about the
history that shapes the world
that we live in right now.
In part it's the fresh material
like the Aristarchus material
that Andrew just discussed,
the de Bude correspondence
that Jim's analyzed, but
it's also a chance to think
about how we can see
things in a fresh light,
make new connections or
create an entirely new frame
of reference or subjective
analysis.
We can use it to see people
and subjects that may have been
or may have seemed to be
marginal to its interest
that is the interest
of the court
but in fact incredibly
important,
especially in an American
and Atlantic context.
And the Omohundro
Institute's chief investment
in this project is
entirely along these lines.
To take the opportunity of this
incredible archive that bear
so importantly on our
country's early history,
to illuminate fresh
histories of early America
and the Atlantic world.
Just one of these potential
topics is the nature
of 18th century women's
intellectual exchange.
In the 18th century, a
robust intellectual exchange
across the Atlantic,
sometimes called the Republic
of Letters included
philosophers, scientists,
and statesmen from England and
the continent, and Americans
such as most famously
probably Benjamin Franklin
and Thomas Jefferson.
Now this developing web
of intellectual connection
was fueled by an exchange
of writing, mostly letters
and other manuscript material
but also printed books,
treatises, pamphlets.
Jefferson and Franklin produced
and received roughly 10,000
and 15,000 letters respectively
in their lifetimes giving
you some idea of the volume
of this Republic of Letters
and anybody who's tried
to get their email inbox down
to zero can appreciate the size
of this endeavor.
Scholars have mapped
the Republic of Letters
in putting data on
authors and recipients
to produce data visualization.
There's actually
terrific project
out at Stanford University
called Mapping the Republic
of Letters.
For America, the primary
observation of mapping
that republic is
that the Republic
of Letters looks very focused
on England and particularly
on London networks that
is for the Americans
who are participating.
And of course the most
elaborate work has been done
on the primarily male
participants in these networks.
But women's literally
and intellectual networks
were also flourishing
in the 18th century.
And they may not yield to
the kinds of data points
and mapping approach but the
voluminous correspondents of men
like Jefferson and
Franklin might,
but rather take some teasing
out of themes and influences.
Now scholars have studied
closely what's known
as the bluestocking circle
of women writers in England.
And other scholars have also
studied early American groups
of women, particularly in
the urban hubs of Boston,
Philadelphia, and New
York who are writing
and reading one another's work.
How might these groups
have intersected
and what can the
Georgian Papers illuminate
in fresh possibilities
about these women writers?
So, I want to invite to take
three quick steps with me
through women's transatlantic
connection centering
on intellectual and
literally concerns.
The first concerns, two of the
most prominent women of England
and America, respectively,
Catharine Macaulay
and Mercy Otis Warren,
whose connection offers us
just a quick place to begin.
Macaulay was one of the most
prominent public women in an era
in which very few women were
either and certainly not
as intellectual as we've
heard already a lot
about princesses and mistresses.
She was known colloquially
as the female historian.
Macaulay wrote a history
of 17th century England,
the history of England from
the ascension of James I
to the revolution
in eighth volumes
with the first volume
published in 1763
and the last 20 years
later in 1783.
This was a political history
that is a history of politics
and governance but also a quite
politically charged history.
It [inaudible] for mostly Whigs
and was seen as a kind small
"r" republican work
and anti-royalist,
though not necessary
straightforwardly so.
She was incredibly
critical of Oliver Cromwell.
For example, she called
him a glorious usurper.
She's a great writer.
I hear applause out there
for being glorious
usurper, OK [laughs].
Macaulay's history was praised
by major figures of the day
in England even by
William Pitt for examples
in the House of Commons.
Mercy Otis Warren's
life was marked
by the revolutionary
era in which she lived.
Born of a mayflower family
mother and a lawyer father,
mercy and her siblings
were raised and educated
to an extraordinary
high standard.
One of her brothers, James Otis,
for example, authored key text
to the American Revolution such
as the famous pamphlet "Rights
of the British Colonies
Asserted and Proved".
He famously articulated the
principle of no taxation
without representation
in regards to the scheme
to collect taxes on American
consumption of British goods.
Mercy wrote in a variety
of genres including one
of the more significant
publications of the late 1780s,
advocating for the
inclusion of a bill of rights
in the new US constitution.
And in 1805, she published the
product of decades of writing
about the unfolding events
of the revolution
and its aftermath.
Thomas Jefferson wrote that her
rise, progress, and termination
of the American Revolution,
was "a truthful
and insightful account
of the last 30 years
that will furnish a more
instructive lesson to mankind
than any earlier
period in history."
Because of Warren's
increasingly anti-federalist
and Jeffersonian
leanings however,
John Adams who had been a long
time dear friend denounced
the work.
These two extraordinary women,
these two historians, Macaulay
and Warren, maintained a long
and intense correspondence
across two crucial decades.
They began to correspond in
1773 and Warren's last letter
to Macaulay was in May of 1791,
the year that Macaulay died.
In an early exchange
about whether women could
and should express
political opinions,
obviously they were preaching
to one another there,
Mercy Warren wrote to her famous
friend, "I disregard the opinion
that women make but in
different politicians.
When the observations are
just and do honor to the heart
and character, I think it very
immaterial whether they flow
from a female lip or are
thundered in the Senate
in the bolder language
of the other sex."
Macaulay and Warren's
friendship was tested as they
like many other figures in this
period who are deeply involved
and invested disagreed,
sometimes mildly
and sometimes sharply,
sometimes privately
and sometimes actually
quite publicly.
But their mutual
admiration never waned.
Macaulay visited
America for over a year,
beginning in the summer of 1784.
And she spent time
in Boston with Warren
and she actually spent
time at Mount Vernon too,
visiting George and
Martha Washington.
Now that we've established
something of the extent
of women's transatlantic
connections, courtesy of Warren
and Macaulay, let us turn to one
that brings us into the courts
and the Georgian Papers.
This example concerns one
of the 18th century's
most celebrated novelists,
Frances Burney known as Fanny.
Burney was a prodigious diarist.
In fact just this year,
the Guardian described
her edited diaries as one
of the 100 most important
nonfiction works of all time.
She's a great diarist
and great writer.
She published her first novel in
1778 and her second, "Cecilia",
to great acclaim in 1782.
The enthusiastic reception for
"Cecilia" included attention
from the royal family.
The queen urged her
daughters to read it
for amusement and for education.
And in 1785, Queen
Charlotte asked Burney
to accept the position at court,
which the novelist accepted.
She was one of the queen's
ladies for five years,
difficult ones that included
King George III's first intense
period of mental illness.
We've heard quite a bit about
the king's qualities as a sort
of intellectual magpie you might
have gathered he was interested
in all kinds of different
things from agriculture
to astronomy to statecraft.
And Charlotte too had a lively
curiosity for botany, for music,
and language but especially
for history and literature.
She was keen to have
bluestockings around her.
Burney wasn't the only one.
And they remained close.
Burney remained close
to the princesses too
after she left royal service.
Burney's reputation flourished
internationally and in America.
The London edition of "Cecilia"
was advertised as early as 1784
in America and was printed in
an American edition in 1793.
Now these novels are
sometimes described
as precursor to Jane Austin.
They're witty, they're
country house settings.
In these books, the
women are always readers.
And in fact Austin's-- the title
of probably Austin's most
significant novel comes
from a line in "Cecilia" where
a character notes that the whole
of this unfortunate
business has been the result
of pride and prejudice.
Burney' reputation
among American educators
in particular only grew.
As the 19th century
dawned, there was a rush
of new academies founded for the
education of privileged girls
in America and an embrace
of the value of education
for free girls of elite families
as a benefit to the
new republic.
Among the great writers and
advocates was another Bostonian,
Judith Sargent Murray.
She was an early advocate
for equality of the sexes,
publishing an essay by that
name in 1790, well in advance
of Mary Wollstonecraft in fact.
And she gathered her many
essays together in 1798.
Just as Americans were
beginning to think
about creating a new national
literature and she published
in three volumes "The Gleaner",
which incorporated
her political views
and especially her interest
in women's education.
And she'd go on to
found a women's--
a girl school herself
with two friends in 1802.
And in "The Gleaner" which
Murray is publishing in 1798,
she advocated for the value
of Burney's novels,
especially "Cecilia".
In a period when novels were
often dismissed as frivolous
or not reflective of the
virtues of the new nation,
there's actually a very snarky
John Quincy Adams quote about
"Cecilia" specifically.
But Murray and others made
clear that in their reflections
on character and circumstances,
novels could be essential
reading and learning.
And here of course she's
echoing Queen Charlotte
who if you remember
advocated Burney's books
for her daughters
for the same reasons.
And now let's bring
this quickly together.
The transatlantic connections
among women intellectuals,
they were reading one another's
work, writing about one another
and even directly communicating,
in fact across political--
what we might think of
as political device.
My third example here
concerns the place of history
in geography in women's
education in the late 18th
and early 19th century.
In those early female academies,
like the one Judith
Sargent Murray helped found,
the curriculum included novels
in place of course in poetry
but it also emphasize
the importance of history
and geography essential
to the education of women
as Denisons [phonetic]
of this new nation.
And here you'll see on
the right there an example
from a Quaker school right
outside of Philadelphia
where teachers created their
own textbooks of poetry
and also had their students
create their own globes.
This stitched globe is actually
it's got hardcore interior
and batting around it and
there are number of examples
from this particular school,
the Westtown School,
as well as others.
And then the longitude
is stitched.
It's really faded there but
it's a really beautiful object.
It's [inaudible]
center right now
at the Boston Public Library.
This stitched globe
helped these young women
as they had male
students for centuries,
not only with basic
geographical orientation
but with geometry and astronomy.
And back inside Windsor
Castle, Queen Charlotte,
her six daughters, the
princesses and their governesses
and ladies in waiting
like Frances Burney were
creating curricula of their own.
The Queen established at
Frogmore House a private retreat
on the grounds at Windsor,
a printing press of her own.
And there, among
many others projects,
they created boxed
sets of historical
and geographical information.
Here you see, on
the top left there,
an example of a manuscript
version, which on that kind
of upper left there
in the center what you
see is a whole bunch
of those manuscript
cards stacked together
with their own really
beautiful box next to it.
So, even the manuscript rough
draft copy gets a beautiful
leather box.
Anyway, and then you also
see the printed cards there.
So you can see how they
were printed at Frogmore,
on the press at Frogmore.
Printed cards and boxes
about Spain, Germany, France,
Portugal, and Rome, or United
States of America you'd say.
So how might these have
reflected the work of some
of the important historian
of the day like Macaulay?
The queen herself was also
writing historical accounts
that reflected her
veracious reading.
She may have been like her
husband and many others
of their era copying
work she read
or combining her own thoughts
and words with those of others.
And I've been reading in
her historical accounts.
She began to keep careful track
for example of the history
and lineage of Sophia,
Electress of Hanover.
There are two copies in
the queen's handwriting
of the lineage of Sophia.
Why would she be
writing multiple times
about Sophia the
Electress of Hanover?
Well, those of you
who know your 17th
and 18th century English
history will know exactly why.
Because this was-- She was
the granddaughter of James I
and this was the lineage that
would shift the British monarchy
from the Stewarts to the
Hanovers with George I
and would bring Charlotte
to England
as the consort of George III.
She wrote out this
history of Sophia,
Electress of Hanover
multiple times.
How meaningful that was
and yet how contested
in the many histories
of the 17th century
and earlier that she had read.
How consequential in
the 18th centuries
through to what she was living.
These are just a few of
the extraordinary stories
and connections that we can
pull out of the Georgian Papers.
And I want to suggest
that if you want
to explore the Georgian
Papers yourself,
the items are being digitized
and then released
online in trenches.
There are about 50,000
items already on the website
and they're being released
and rolling about 25
to 30,000 items at a time.
And you can begin by looking
at our three project websites.
To read more about the
blog post and information
about the GPPU can consult the
Omohundro Institute and William
and Mary site which is
georgianpapers-us.wm.edu.
We'll post all these
staff for you.
And the King's site which
is georgianpapersprogramme,
with an extra M-E dot com.
These are mirror sites and
they express our mutual
and ongoing scholarly work.
The papers themselves
along with some
of the academic commentarial
including pieces by all
of us are at
gpp.royalcollection.org.uk.
And if you toggle to
the upper right there,
you'll see the GPP micro site.
And that has at least
50,000 items
that are already posted some
of the materials
we've shared with you.
But more all the time is this
project continues through 2020.
Thank you so much
for your time today.
[Applause]
>> Dr. Colleen J. Shogan: OK.
So now we're going to ask all
of our presenters to come back
up on stage and it's
time for you,
you've been very
patient audience,
if you have questions for them.
We have about 20 or 25 minutes.
And we also have microphones
coming around the room.
So when I call on you,
please wait until the
microphone arrives.
Is there anybody
that has questions?
Yes, over here.
Yeah, just wait for
the microphone, please.
>> So, best estimate,
overall, what percentage
of papers have been
at least indexed?
>> Karin Wulf: It depends on
what you mean by indexing.
I mean, there's a kind of--
there's a rough look
at the whole--
the pie chart that Arthur showed
you, you know, is from a kind
of rough cut look, but when
you say index, nothing.
>> Arthur Burns: Possibly
even less than 15%, in fact.
>> Karin Wulf: Yes.
>> Arthur Burns:
Is a real indexing.
>> Karin Wulf: Yeah.
>> Arthur Burns: So you can--
What's on the outside of
the box, we can tell you.
>> Karin Wulf: Yeah.
>> Arthur Burns:
Beyond that, no.
>> Andrew O'Shaughnessy: I
thought I'd been deficient
because I kept expecting
it would be somewhere kind
of printed manuscript
guide that you have
for almost every archive
and it doesn't exist.
And one of the problems reminds
me a little once I mentioned
this to Karin, Gary
Hart [assumed spelling]
when he was asked to
investigate the CIA and FBI
with Barry Goldwater and he
said we didn't know what we were
looking for [laughs].
And that is the difficulty,
always nervous
as to whether you're awfully
aware of exactly what is there
or if there are boxes that you
just haven't been told about.
You rely a lot of course
on the on-site librarians
to tell you what they have.
But I would stop by going
to the published
Fortescue correspondence.
So at least you can get a sense
of what you might find in there.
>> Jim Ambuske: A few weeks
before my arrival I was sent a
spreadsheet, an Excel
spreadsheet
that essentially had, as Arthur
said, an indication on what was
on the label on the box.
Some sense of what had
been published before
in Fortescue [inaudible]
and that was it.
So, there was very little
[inaudible] sub-collections.
So one of the cool things about
this submission is that I got
to work with Oliver Walton
and the archivist to figure
out what was actually in these
things and then we all did.
>> Arthur Burns: That's
the other you can do.
You can become a King's friend.
And if you sign up to King's
friends, we're very happy
for anyone to say I'm looking
for this, what have you got?
And we will follow that up.
And actually [inaudible] we
don't know what's in there,
what we might want to find,
the more people would tell
us what they'd like to find,
the more we can try to find it.
>> Karin Wulf: The other
thing I would just say--
I know there are other
questions, so sorry--
but is that some of
the fellows have gone
to the archives looking
for particular topics
and the not finding has been
a significant as the finding.
There's a wonderful blog
post on our mutual sites
by Professor Cynthia Kierner
from George Mason
University who's been working
on a wonderful book about
early American disasters.
And she was actually going
in search of information
about the royal philanthropy
because--
which really takes off
in a big way starting
with the 1755 Lisbon earthquake.
And she wanted to
know what did they say
about their incredible
philanthropic efforts
and the answer was
almost nothing.
And just the fact that they were
so little there tells
you something.
Anyway she's got-- I
won't give it all away
but it's a wonderful blog post
about why finding nothing can be
as important and revealing
and tells us actually
as much as finding a lot.
>> Dr. Colleen J.
Shogan: Other question?
Right here.
>> All of you have spoken
about collections of objects,
things that can be
listed in spreadsheets.
But when you make a digital
collection, it seems to me
if you look to the future
information technology,
which happens to be my
specialty not history,
allows you to build graphs
of links into my new elements
in different objects,
different documents.
And if someone looking
ahead to how
such a metadata can be
created to address themes
and documenting whatever
historical findings they have
by linking many different
places not just
in the Georgian Papers
collection
but even collections
that are related.
>> Arthur Burns: So, it's a real
challenge and it's something
that was quite a few on the team
have worked [inaudible] basic
ways are fully aware of and also
just what an opportunity it is.
The peculiar challenges with
this collection is partly is
because of the range
of the materials in it.
So the expertise you need
to produce a metadata is
extraordinarily wide ranging
in this case.
So again, what we're
trying to bring people in,
it could be part of the
conversation that we're trying
to get it right and there
are lots of examples in UK,
I'm sure that are here too,
places where they got it wrong
and it's left with
metadata unusable,
at least because there
have changes in their name
so [inaudible] all English
politicians always have
about four different titles
and the most famous examples
with the British parliamentary
archive that failed
to realize the same people
in the metadata creation,
link them together.
So we have a very good team
of digital humanist at King's
and at William and Mary
who are working together
on these issues.
We hope we'll be able
to make a start on it,
probably to make a
success of it we'll need
to get a funding going
that would build that.
But it's very much
something that's in my mind
and also trying to think how
we provide web architecture
and we'll have other people join
with us to do that throughout
and to do it entirely
on our own.
>> Karin Wulf: And there's been
a wonderful initiative here
at the Library of Congress
actually to fund questions
about interoperability
and making collections.
>> Dr. Colleen J. Shogan:
That was our first four away
into the project is--
Is Charlotte here?
Charlotte?
Charlotte Caslick [assumed
spelling] was a digital
stewardship resident
that we actually sent
to Windsor for several months.
She was in residence here
then residence in Windsor
and she was working on the issue
of metadata inoperability
particularly between the Library
of Congress collections
and the GPP collections.
OK. Yes, in the back.
>> We're pretty certain
about the nature
of George III's madness but
I was wondering of this sheds
in any new light on how it--
or its incipient stages may
have affected policy in Britain.
>> Andrew O'Shaughnessy: He
had about sickness at the time
of [inaudible] in the 1765,
which went on for months.
So that was actually the
first intimation of it.
But there's no evidence that
he was sick during the American
Revolution itself.
It was really on the eve
of the French Revolution
that he had the first
sustained belt that was
in fact the subject to the movie
"The Madness of King George".
The thinking seems
to be changing.
For decades, they thought
that this was porphyria.
It's a mother-son
team of psychiatrists.
And I thought that they've
made quite a conclusive case
because there's a giveaway
characteristic of porphyria
which is a blood disease
caused often by intermarriage,
very like hemophilia but it's
kind of purple-colored urine.
And so-- And one of the
doctors constantly alluded
to urine color and we've
got incredible archives
of the doctor's reports.
But it seems that
it's changing again.
I've actually seen this in
the BBC, an academic article
that they're going back to
thinking that he was bipolar
and that would make
a difference.
But-- And there's nothing
of the characteristics
of the later madness of then
in 1765 and then again 1789.
>> Arthur Burns: What you
do find is that an awareness
on politicians, the key moments
that something going
before it becomes clear.
That's just how extensive the
problems are and the effort
to manage the news
around the [inaudible].
>> What happened in this second
decade of the 21st century
that after all these years
the crown decided or somebody
in England decided to
open these archives?
>> Arthur Burns: So
I think that a number
of different things
come together,
one is just the technical
possibilities doing this
that other people done it
to the [inaudible] for it.
The [inaudible] has begun
with smaller projects they
took Queen Victoria's journal
for example and made
those online.
And I think we've taken it
back that we have interest
that were shown in,
in that project
and that was behind
the [inaudible],
so this was the first way to be
to do it would genuinely
open resource
with academic collaborators.
I think the second feature is
that the royal archives having
under pressure to
become more public.
There's been a lot
of interesting things
in 20th century, royal
family in their papers.
Obviously there's been
quite tricky issues
about personal [inaudible]
people still alive
and I think what they wanted
to show is their overarching
mission to treat these
as public documents
even though they're
in fact private documents which
is part of a national heritage
and therefore there's been--
it's extraordinary
effort I think
for those [inaudible]
party was very,
very hard unless you were
fully tenured professor
with a very particular project
even to get to see what was then
because there were no catalogs.
You could find out until
you got there what they was.
And now it was full of
people, not just with us,
there are an awful lot
but actually they've
read on the reading room.
There's now more opportunities
to go in and use the papers.
They've increased their opening.
So it's a genuine attempt.
I think it's very rewarding
for the archivist there too
that they found they
been able to do their job
of interpretation
and understanding
far more actually now
that there are more changes
towards people [inaudible].
It's a very well [inaudible].
>> Karin Wulf: Given the
restriction there and it is
where a monarch lives.
So the security restrictions are
pretty intense and, you know,
the restriction on
what can be done
within that space
are pretty intense.
Given all that I think they've
been really extraordinary
about opening access to
these archival materials.
And, you know, if you go
to the website, you know,
anybody all over the
world can freely see.
And by 2020, you know, anybody
all over the world can see all
of the Georgian Papers
collection digitally.
Well, anybody with a, you know,
connection in the
computer anyway.
>> Arthur Burns: And it is all--
I think that's quite
important to emphasize.
It's not the sense
of selection--
>> Karin Wulf: Yeah,
it's everything.
>> Arthur Burns:
It's the archive.
>> Dr. Colleen J.
Shogan: Another question.
Yes, down in front.
>> Those were four
fabulous presentations.
I can't tell you how
they fit together
and also stood on their own.
[ Applause ]
And I care about 18th
century British history.
But I want to ask a little
bit about Fanny Burney
and how this might help
in teaching working
with graduate students in
women's and gender history.
Have you thought about that?
>> Karin Wulf: Well,
so, you know,
I'm not a Fanny Burney
expert and there are those,
many of them actually, so
I don't want to suggest
that somehow I know something
that other scholars don't.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is why I said, well,
we'll post a bibliography
on our websites for
people who are interested.
But I think that the
teaching possibilities
for the GPP generally
are going to be terrific
and the Fanny Burney
material will be great.
I'm not sure if is that's me
squeaking or someone else.
>> No.
>> Karin Wulf: OK.
All right.
Good. You could see
I've got a little PTSD
from that BBC documentary
[laughter].
But the teaching
possibilities are great.
I mean, Arthur really
did this amazing project
with his undergraduates in
King's and we've been talking
about a kind of collaborative
effort at William and Mary
and King's to teach
with the GPP materials
to give the students
a kind of, you know,
a one-shot one year kind
of informal seminar
research experience.
But I think all over, the
access to this materials
and to link them up-- I
mean, this is, you know,
linking sometimes in
the old-fashioned way
of I thought this and
now I've thought of that,
but also digitally
linking things is going
to make curricular
possibilities,
really extraordinary.
And, you know, the
obvious, I think,
topics here are the
political and military ones.
And I just went for the
easiest women's history one here
which is the intellectual women
who are writing and publishing
and who are among the
most famous, you know,
of 18th century Anglo-American
women.
But the women's history
opportunities in these archives
and the opportunities to link
materials in those archives
with other archives here
in the United States
is really incredible.
There are all kinds of things
we can learn about, you know,
women's consumption
patterns, about food,
about ideas about the body.
And there are just-- Anyway,
they are just endless
opportunities
and those will translate
to teaching.
>> Arthur Burns: I
think one thing you have
to example is Princess Amelia
and her experience
of consumption.
Now there's another
extraordinary medical
case history.
Lived from the inside by royal
princess has also infatuated one
of your queries, so does the
extraordinary romantic story
of that new kind of
romantic love being embodied
in that situation in
[inaudible], days we're looking
at that, an extraordinary
material that she's found there.
And that was a great story
about how digital works as well,
because we broadcast the
documentary on the BBC
and there's a brief
section where Flora Fraser,
one of our fellows who is one
of our Mount Vernon
professors, talks about this.
And the next day, I got a
friendly call from somewhere
in the north saying, "I
think I've got the other half
of the correspondence."
And it was ascendant
to one of the queries
that she's involved with.
So we've been up there.
We haven't yet found what we
can do that an idea would be
to digitize those documents
and bring those in as well.
And that's what you
can do with digital.
You can create virtual
archives without having to mess
about with physical
archives themselves.
And it's fantastic
we can do that.
>> Karin Wulf: Those medical--
The medical history as a kind
of theme throughout is really
compelling with George III
of course and Amelia
and Fanny Burney has one
of the most famous women's
medical histories of the period
where she, you know,
narrated her own mastectomy.
She writes about
having done it under--
you know, with no anesthesia.
It's a really extraordinary
document in women's history.
>> Yes?
>> I'd read recently in
recent years about the--
that one of the key
reasons for the loss in 1780
in Cornwallis was that
half of the British troops
in America had been diverted
to the West Indies
to protect the sugar.
And given what you've
referred to as--
and we've seen other places
about the king's involvement
of this, it's hard to quite
imagine him either suggesting
or allowing that diversion.
Is there anything that's
come to light about that?
>> Andrew O'Shaughnessy: He
actually supported that policy
and said, "We can't even
fight the American war
without our sugar items."
And so in 1778, when the British
had occupied Philadelphia,
the new commander-in-chief Henry
Clinton was given orders to give
up Philadelphia to
send 5000 troops
down to the Caribbean
to take Saint Lucia.
And then in the summer of 1779,
the British received warning
that Jamaica was
about to be invaded.
They put their entire army
in New York onboard ship
with Cornwallis and they were
at sea for almost a week.
So this really shows
you the priorities.
They did lose a large number
of their islands
during the revolution.
But it seems to have been kind
of one compromise they're
willing to make was
to lose Jamaica, So they're
actually sending more troops
to the West Indies in the second
of the American Revolution
then to America.
>> Dr. Colleen J.
Shogan: Over here?
>> Thanks again to all of you
for wonderful presentations.
I'm wondering if any
of you has any sense
that this project might
stimulate contextualization
with parallel archives
for example among the royal
houses elsewhere in Europe
or perhaps even more
pertinently,
papers of British aristocratic
families and households and so
on or perhaps such
already exist?
>> Arthur Burns: So, we
know already there are one
or two other projects that
are beginning to talk to us,
some of the kind that you've
mentioned is we've got an
addition of one
of the courtier's papers that's
proceeding in Manchester.
They're not talking
to us, we're hoping
to align transcription,
launch that.
And there are various
tensions raised
and [inaudible] we
hope we'll be able
to build links possibly
even fellowships of the kind
that we've had elsewhere
to bring people
in to work with the papers.
I think the competitive
monarchs things is a point very
well taken.
We're in touch with a scholar
in Leiden, Jeroen Duindam,
who wrote a-- I think it's
a book called Dynasty.
You may know it, which
is global history
of monarchy in any
modern period.
He's just got some
money to do a project
on Northern European monarchies.
And I'm talking to him about
what we might be able to do
at some point for the workshops
to bring those together.
And I think that that's
precisely the kind of thing
that we want to see happen.
And one of the nice thing about
the project, in some ways,
it's a very unusual project.
And we don't have a
research question.
And usually now, when
you set out in Britain,
like if you got a
particular question, you say,
this is where I'm going to find
the answer and you hope you do
and that's why you give
them the money to do it.
Here, probably because we aren't
funded in a big research project
without a single question,
we can follow what the
archives suggest to us.
And the key to that is making
sure enough people know
about what we're doing
and that's what links
with them the Library
of Congress and others.
It's so important that we can
then make those connections
for as wide an audience
as you possibly can.
And it's the fun of it too.
>> Jim Ambuske: I think there's
evidence that it's beginning
to inspire the project.
So we were just in
Scotland three weeks ago
at our Scottish Records
Conference and met
with the archivist at the Duke--
of Duke of Argyll at
the Inveraray Castle.
And they are beginning
to make public
and more accessible not
necessarily to digital means
but more accessible, the
papers of the Dukes of Argyll
who are the most powerful
family in 18th century Scotland.
And so you're getting
to see, you know,
I think some momentum
built up to open
up these once very closed
bases to new research.
>> Karin Wulf: I'll just add
one quick thing there which is
that through these back
and forth fellowships
of having fellows in one archive
and then in the other at Windsor
and at the Library of Congress
and hopefully in other back
and forth spaces, you commit the
fellows really to helping talk
to all of us about what's
mutually in those things.
We can read an academic
monograph and see, oh,
you've used archival materials
in this place and this place.
They must connect
in some logical way.
But because the fellows are, you
know, fellows of the project,
they actually provide
support back to the project
on exactly these
questions of linkages.
>> Arthur Burns: One of
the interesting things
about our period, I
think, is attentive
of what situation the
US is but in the UK,
the 18th century is the most
digital of all centuries.
More pioneering work is being
done in digital amenities.
We have the Old Bailey online
where every criminal case
at that Old Bailey
is readable online.
We have records of all
the London workhouses.
We have records of every
murder that happened
in London plotted onto maps.
And so all these things
might include your database
for every [inaudible]
you bring those together
and we're beginning
to create a kind
of unique digital environment
as well, which we can just--
there's a thing called connected
histories now where you can type
in John-- well, don't
type in John Smith.
But if you found a slightly
more unusual name, type it in,
and it will tell you which of
those databases have references
to that name.
And the possibility of
linking them all up in
that way is a very exciting
and slightly daunting
prospect as well.
>> Dr. Colleen J. Shogan: We
have time for one more question.
OK. Well, that brings
us to the end
of the formal part
of our proceedings.
Once again, I would like to
thank Mrs. Beverly Hamilton
for her generous sponsorship.
Great public programming
like today's event
is made possible only
through the support
of people like you.
If you'd like to help
the library offer more
of these types of programs,
please consider making a
gift at loc.gov/donate.
Please join us now for our
reception and a viewing
of a selection of
British Political cartoons
from the Library of Congress
Collection which were purchased
from Windsor Castle
in the 1920s.
In great British tradition, we
have tea and scones available.
However, our conscientious
library staff tell me
that you cannot take your
tea and scones into the room
where we have the materials.
So please enjoy your
refreshments
and also enjoy the terrific
treasures on display.
We hope you have a
great afternoon here
at the Library of Congress.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.